[...failed to convert the significant
reduction in crime that is there…]
You murderer!
[...and with no end in sight to this wave of crime.]
Everyone knows you’ve fancied Lucy since forever.
Tom? Come by later, yeah?
Sure.
Lucy?
[phone number dial]
You were very lucky.
Phone fragments here...
and here missed the temporal lobe, but...
Will there be any side-effects?
If anything unusual happens,
I want you to let me know straight away.
[There’s a boy staring at me.]
Never been the victim.
I should’ve done something...
No one's mad at you for not being a hero.
They were there!
What’re you talking about?
At Lucy’s!
I KNOW WHAT YOU DID
I’ve heard there was some sort of vigilante or something...
...who’s trying to take on the gangs.
Got ya.
You don’t call the devil, then get upset when he turns up.
Where, oh where is Lucy?
I’m gonna bury you both down.
They won’t get away with it.
You're f*cked up!
You're a special kid, Tom.
The special kid.
[subtitles & timing by chibikTLT]